Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
Per chi di voi non fosse
appassionato di cinematografia,
o per chi dovesse aver vissuto su Marte
negli ultimi 38 anni,
quello che avete appena visto
è il monologo finale di un film
del regista americano Ridley Scott,
del 1982 - peraltro mio anno di nascita.
Un film che è stato in grado
di trascendere tempo e spazio
e differenze generazionali,
e divenire un pilastro
della cultura pop mondiale:
Blade Runner.
Blade Runner è un film
che rimane nel mondo
non perché il regista era bravissimo,
e gli attori ancor più eccezionali:
abbiamo visto Rutger Hauer.
Ma perché tutte le volte che lo vediamo
ci sentiamo un pochino male.
È una sorta di disagio
che sentiamo distintamente,
e di cui tuttavia
non possiamo fare a meno,
perché origina da una domanda
che risuona in ognuno di noi.
Una domanda che è in grado
di mettere in discussione
tutto ciò che sappiamo,
o pensiamo di sapere, sull'esistenza.
E questa domanda è:
"Ma gli androidi
sognano pecore elettriche?"
Lo so, per molti di voi questa domanda
è totalmente priva di senso.
Però "Do Androids Dream
of Electric Sheep?"
è il titolo del romanzo
dell'autore americano Philip K. Dick
che dà origine al mito di Blade Runner.
Dick percorre gli stessi passi
di autori come Isaac Asimov,
ma prende la letteratura sci-fi
e la porta a nuovi orizzonti:
orizzonti postmoderni,
post-umani e post-umanistici.
Essenzialmente, Dick crea
il movimento "cyberpunk":
un universo distopico,
in cui la grande evoluzione tecnologica
ridefinisce le dinamiche
e le gerarchie sociali.
In cui la tecnologia
mette in discussione, essenzialmente,
il ruolo dell'uomo al centro del mondo,
il nostro umanesimo.
L'umanesimo, appunto, è quella prospettiva
per cui l'uomo si sostituisce a Dio,
rifiutandolo -
e diventa centro del tutto
grazie alla sua capacità di logica,
al suo intelletto
e alla sua capacità di empatizzare
con ciò che ci circonda.
Nel suo libro e nel film, Blade Runner,
il regista e l'autore ci chiedono:
ma cosa c'è di così particolare nell'uomo
da porlo al centro del tutto?
Dick ci presenta
un futuro oscuro e senza sole,
dove piove sempre come unico rimedio
per contrastare l'insostenibile
inquinamento atmosferico,
in cui uomini e androidi convivono,
in cui l'egemonia culturale
e politica è asiatica.
In questo mondo,
l'intelligenza artificiale
ha sostituito l'elettricità
alla base di una nuova rivoluzione
economica e sociale.
E l'uomo compie, grazie alla tecnologia,
un ulteriore slittamento
nel suo ruolo del tutto.
Dopo essersi sostituito a Dio,
diviene egli stesso Dio
e creatore di una genia
di esseri artificiali -
gli androidi, appunto -
costruiti e creati
a propria immagine e somiglianza
con lo scopo di superare
la limitatezza dell'uomo.
Gli androidi sono più belli,
più intelligenti, più forti degli uomini;
ma l'uomo deve comunque conservare
il proprio centro nel mondo.
E quindi, li crea
con una vita molto molto breve,
con la giustificazione che
"la fiamma che brilla
al doppio di luminosità
brucia in metà tempo".
Alcuni androidi, però, si ribellano
e decidono di mischiarsi agli uomini
per cercare di incontrare
il proprio creatore,
per chiedere di vivere
un pochettino in più.
Si rende quindi necessario chiedere
quale sia la differenza
tra uomini e androidi.
La domanda dell'autore
diventa ancor più evidente.
Cos'è che ci differenzia?
Cos'è che ci dà il diritto
di porci comunque al centro del mondo,
soprattutto adesso che logica,
intelletto e forza fisica
sono degli androidi?
La risposta è il Voight-Kampff test.
Un test, del tutto fittizio,
che serve per determinare
se un soggetto esaminato
è in grado di provare empatia
con ciò che lo circonda.
L'empatia, quindi, diventa
ciò che realmente ci distingue.
È una sorta di upgrade
del cogito ergo sum cartesiano,
"Penso, quindi sono",
che è sostituito dal
"I feel, therefore I am":
io sento, quindi sono umano,
e degno di vivere.
E non è un caso che il protagonista,
il nome del protagonista, Rick Deckart,
sia una trasposizione letterale
di Réné Descartes, cioè di Cartesio.
La cosa incredibile,
all'interno del film e del libro,
è che ad un certo punto,
considerando che gli androidi
riescono a provare empatia -
avete visto, Roy
salva Rick, alla fine -
noi ci troviamo a empatizzare
con gli androidi,
e quasi a desiderare che,
come noi ci siamo sostituiti a Dio,
loro si sostituiscano a noi,
che siamo il loro Dio.
Perché vi ho raccontato
questa storia, e perché adesso?
Perché nonostante manchino
ancora un po' di anni,
al realizzarsi di questo tipo di futuro,
la traiettoria verso cui
sembriamo essere direzionati
sembra abbastanza segnata.
Consideriamo una legge fondamentale
dell'I.C.T., la "Legge di Moore".
La Legge di Moore dice che ogni due anni
la capacità computazionale
delle macchine raddoppia.
In una società che si basa
così endemicamente sulla tecnologia,
se ogni due anni
la capacità computazionale
delle macchine raddoppia,
la distanza che ci separa
dal nostro futuro
ogni due anni dimezza.
La realtà è che l'intelligenza artificiale
si sta già sostituendo all'elettricità,
e presto noi dovremmo shiftare
da una programmazione per un profitto
alla creazione per un valore.
Facciamo un passo indietro:
quando noi pensiamo
all'intelligenza artificiale,
probabilmente pensiamo a un computer
che gioca a scacchi,
e batte il campione del mondo di scacchi.
Quel computer era Deep Blue, di IBM;
quel campione del mondo di scacchi
era Garry Kasparov;
e l'anno era il 1997,
che in ere tecnologiche
è come dire la preistoria.
Vediamo cosa succede, o cosa è successo,
in questi ultimi annetti.
Nel 2016,
un algoritmo di intelligenza artificiale
sconfigge il campione del mondo di Go,
che è il gioco considerato
l'epitome dell'intelletto umano:
un trilione di trilioni
di trilioni di combinazioni
superiore al gioco di scacchi,
per cui un trilione di trilioni
di trilioni di volte
più difficile del gioco di scacchi.
Questo algoritmo gioca
contro sé stesso per un paio d'ore,
va contro il campione del mondo
e lo batte, utilizzando delle tecniche
assolutamente incomprensibili a noi.
Nel 2016, oplà: conquistiamo
la parità uomo- macchina,
cioè la macchina riesce
a riconoscere gli oggetti
altrettanto bene rispetto agli uomini.
Nel 2017, la voice recognition:
le macchine comprendono la voce
esattamente come noi.
Questo nel 2017, tre anni fa.
Nel 2018,
hanno la stessa accuratezza
nel rispondere alle domande;
nel 2019, riescono a tradurre
tutti i migliaia di dialetti del cinese
in inglese, altrettanto bene.
Quindi mi sembra logico
che la logica, appunto, e l'intelletto
siano stati "matchati",
o addirittura, in alcuni casi, superati.
Cosa resta agli uomini?
L'arte, ovviamente: vero Chiara?
Chi è la poetessa
più seguita del mondo, oggi?
La poetessa più seguita del mondo,
con oltre 700 milioni di lettori,
è XiaoIce,
un'intelligenza artificiale di Microsoft.
Che non solo scrive,
ma conduce sette programmi televisivi
e canta anche delle canzoni.
Un altro bellissimo progetto -
sempre per te, Chiara -
è "The Next Rembrandt Project",
che nel 2017 ha visto
un'intelligenza artificiale,
sempre di Microsoft,
studiare tutti i capolavori di Rembrandt,
in modo approfondito.
Poi l'hanno collegato ad una stampante 3D,
e da solo - l'abbiamo lasciato
libero di esprimersi -
ha creato un nuovo dipinto.
Un nuovo dipinto
che tutti gli esperti
di Rembrandt del mondo
avrebbero attribuito
al grande pittore fiammingo.
Ovviamente, oggi sapete
che il 95 percento del valore
di tutto ciò che noi
consideriamo di valore
viene attribuito
su un'operazione semantica -
il riconoscimento di un simbolo,
e l'attribuzione di un significato -
che è fatta da un uomo.
La verità - by the way,
cosa è successo a quel quadro
non l'abbiamo mai saputo:
però c'è, da qualche parte.
La verità è che l'intelligenza artificiale
si sta già, come abbiamo detto,
sostituendo all'elettricità.
E come negli anni Sessanta e Settanta
le catene di montaggio
sono state automatizzate,
una parte dei nostri lavori -
però quelli più spersonalizzanti -
verranno automatizzati:
queste sono le richieste
di intelligenza artificiale.
Quindi ci troviamo a chiedere:
cosa è il nostro posto nel mondo?
Qual è, cosa ci determina
al centro del mondo?
Ancora una volta, la nostra empatia
determinerà il nostro posto,
il tipo di futuro.
È utopico? Distopico? Magari più giusto?
La verità è che in questo momento
abbiamo la possibilità
di correggere gli errori
attraverso l'empatia,
di capire la creazione, per un valore -
verso quale valore creare.
Ma come sta la nostra
empatia, ultimamente?
Facciamo un piccolo esperimento:
iniziamo a pensare di avere
un algoritmo di intelligenza artificiale,
e gli diciamo: "Abbiamo un'azienda.
Assumimi i migliori
professionisti in assoluto".
E gli diamo tutti i dati
di tutte le aziende
della storia dell'economia,
con tutti i dati
di tutti i professionisti
della storia dell'economia.
Visto che l'intelligenza artificiale,
e la qualità dell'output,
dipende dal valore del dato
e dalla bontà del dato,
quello che oggi questa
intelligenza artificiale produrrebbe
è un uomo di 40 anni, bianco.
Perché ovviamente,
nella storia siamo soggetti
a un sacco di preconcetti,
di discriminazioni, di pay gap.
Quindi vi richiedo:
com'è il nostro Stato empatico,
in questo momento?
Il nostro sostegno sovranista, oggi,
è a due punti percentuali
sotto quello che era nel 1939.
Vi ricorda qualcosa, il 1939?
Qual è il percorso su cui ci muoviamo?
Siamo in mondo che costruisce muri,
che "li aiuta a casa loro",
che li lascia sui barconi
del Mediterraneo,
che mette prima gli italiani,
prima gli americani, prima gli inglesi?
Siamo un mondo molto distopico,
quindi il futuro
non può che essere distopico.
E la cosa perversa
è che abbiamo smesso di creare,
e di cercare empaticamente un valore,
ma cerchiamo di confermare i nostri bias,
come se fosse Juventus-Inter:
una cosa di puro tifo, di puro credo.
Le "fake news" sono all'esplosione.
E questo non è un piccolissimo dettaglio:
questo corrisponde a un'impennata
degli "hate crimes",
della discriminazione.
È questo è il futuro che vogliamo?
Stephen Hawking ci dice
che siamo a rischio di distruggere
la nostra razza umana, la nostra umanità,
a causa della nostra avidità
e della nostra stupidità.
Quindi siamo fregati,
e prima o poi verremo
sostituiti dalle macchine?
No, perché c'è anche chi, fortunatamente,
la pensa in modo diverso
e fa in modo diverso.
Qualcuno prima ha detto:
per essere, bisogna fare.
E sono assolutamente
d'accordo: Bias to action.
Un esempio è Microsoft,
che è anche il motivo
per cui io sono entrato in Microsoft.
Cioè la visione umanistica
della tecnologia
e dell'intelligenza artificiale
usata per dare più potere -
"to empower our people" -
a superare le limitazioni,
a superare le discriminazioni.
Ve ne dò un esempio.
(Inglese): Vedo due visi:
un uomo di 40 anni, con la barba,
che sembra sorpreso;
un uomo di 20 anni che sembra felice.
La App può descrivere
l'età e il genere
delle persone attorno a me,
e quali sono le loro emozioni,
che è incredibile] .....
UC: Questo è un nostro
collega, ipovedente:
grazie ad un algoritmo
di intelligenza artificiale,
riesce a "vedere":
non ha bisogno di qualcuno
che lo accompagni nelle sale riunioni;
riesce a leggere i menu;
riesce a vedere [se] davanti c'è gente
che lo guarda e dice:
ma questo da dove viene?
Oppure dice: ah, ho sentito,
è molto interessante -
Questo è un utilizzo "to empower people",
questo è un utilizzo
"to make the wrong right",
come dicono in America,
cioè per correggere gli errori.
Questo è qualcosa
che vale la pena esplorare,
che ci rende tutti migliori.
Un altro esempio è l'"Inner Eye Project",
un algoritmo - che è stato fatto
col tumore all'occhio,
col tumore al seno,
col tumore al pancreas -
che aumenta del 95% la capacità -
in alcuni casi, il 99% -
di diagnosticare correttamente
una massa tumorale.
Ovviamente, non sto
assolutamente suggerendo
che questa cosa -
che l'intelligenza artificiale
debba sostituirsi ai medici:
non è assolutamente così.
Però, per quanto riguarda
l'Image Matching Recognition,
sicuramente questo è più preciso.
Quindi, liberando il medico
e le sue capacità cognitive -
almeno una parte di questo peso -
oggi il medico può occuparsi
di quello che è più importante,
cioè la gestione del paziente,
la gestione della persona che ha davanti.
Questo è solo uno dei tantissimi esempi
che esistono, degli esempi virtuosi.
Però è essenzialmente la domanda
che vi faccio, è che dipende da noi.
Questo vorrei che capissimo:
dipende solo da noi.
Quindi vi chiedo:
ma sarà il caso che anche noi iniziamo
a sognare pecore elettriche?
Grazie.
(Applausi)